what do you think is the most important
company encrypt over the next 10 years I
was having this debate with someone the
other day um look I think bit main has
been one of these companies that like
has been so underappreciated and just
has silently built an empire
same thing with bitfury we don't really
talk about mining like these companies
are building next generation not just
Bitcoin infrastructure but compute
infrastructure absolutely um and for
blockchain to work at scale the
networking layer has to be really robust
which is gonna require a lot of like
next-gen compute infrastructure and so
we see the existing fabs are just
starting to get on the asic and GPU
mining bandwagon but these guys have
already been there and so I think that's
that's gonna be really interesting to
watch that battle the other company I
think's really underappreciated I mean
everyone talks about finance and like
how revolutionary finance is actually
think people aren't paying enough
attention to platforms like shape to
shape shift and abra and really their
mantra is we were unable users to
transact and invest in trade in a
private secure way these non-custodial
designs I think are really important to
enabling crypto to really spread if we
want to truly create a better financial
system owning your own assets truly
owning your own assets it's really
important and coinbase in finance and
all of these platforms that facilitate
trading they've become central bank's
they become points of failure so I think
companies like abre and shapeshift and
others in this vein who are enabling
trading holding storing where you have
full custodial will you full control and
full discretion over what happens really
critical absolutely let's go back to
mining for a second because I think that
your point about how undervalue these
companies are right so the two things
that are top of mind for me bit made
specifically so one is a lot of people
in the crypto community when they see
success right there's two paths thing go
down one is either they walk right and
hey you know I made a bunch of money and
gonna take it and go enjoy life or the
other is they get really really bold and
ambitious right I think that's what
we're seeing with bit main right is
they're saying look we've had a bunch of
success we've been able to drive a bunch
of capital right they when they their
last round they raised I believed that
outsiders of the company owned less than
5% right all of a sudden now they're
talking a little bit more about
artificial intelligence machine learning
compute that is used for non mining or
non crypto applications and it goes back
to this idea that you know everyone says
date is the new oil right and if data is
the new oil rep in my mouth for everyone
listening right so it's everyone who
says that I always respond with if data
is the new oil computing is the new
steel right because you actually need
the infrastructure to let that whole
data-driven world exist I think the most
underappreciated layer of the crypto
space is the network right so we think
about icos and tokens all the capital
formation is happening at the protocol
layer the application layer it that's or
the VCS like traditional PCs are like I
only do like what are you and they're
investing in applications and then we
see people trying to get around that by
doing these app coin things but no one's
really focusing on that middle layer yep
that enables protocols and technical
design to get implemented in physical
compute space and we see this because
these networks people are building are
not robust like look that's what we'll
look at what's happened with aetherium
look it's happening with es look at like
these new networks that are launching
they're not secure they're not robust
and the problem is is that we're if
we're gonna live in a world with
thousands of block chains they're all
gonna require expression and physical
compute space and where's that
infrastructure gonna come from how
specialized does it need to be and then
does that actually become the new domain
for competition because we can easily
raise capital to protocol area at the
app player but at the networking layer
there's an actual physical constraint to
implementation because there's a limited
amount of compute absolutely and so to
me investing in compute and I want to
create structured products that offer
compute capacity to protocols like if
you raise money through an IC o---- for
your protocol you should be buying
compute with that money you should be
buying dedicated networking
infrastructure that's resilient and
robust and that is secure nd risk so
that your protocol can run in all sorts
of adversarial environments well if you
think of the compute that's previously
been
well it's been very CPU heavy right
because that's what the the networks and
the consumer application successor
we're now moving to a world where Asics
GPUs are becoming much more valuable and
I think you know I've talking about like
the idea to even go and start to get
legacy infrastructure companies under
your control and then start swapping the
CPUs out for GPUs a6 etc super
interesting now it's also really it's a
cost of production game right so if we
think about vertical integration
integrating power production with
manufacturing with actually operating
the facility right this is the perfect
toilet gas example I spent you know
seven years of my career I started my
life in building big infrastructure
projects that took 20 years to build and
cost 20 to 40 billion dollars yep we get
the crypto space right if this is truly
gonna be a massive industry that's
heavily focused on building new network
infrastructure that's resilient security
centralized whatever we need a physical
expression of that that's infrastructure
financing that's very different from
financing a protocol that's structured
finance its principle present interest
and finding new ways to to effectively
like infrastructure financing is all
about reconciling the mismatch of cash
flows right you end up using a bunch of
cash but you don't get any in until five
ten years from now yep same thing in the
crypto space very few people have had
the vision in the foresight to
understand that that networking space
and that physical computer is so
critical well he it was a it's actually
how I got involved in crypto I was how
you and I became friends
what was what so my family's been in the
data center business forever right and
what I saw was in the traditional data
center business space power hardware
operations right in yeah yeah in mining
you have space power hardware and
operations it's just the hardware's
different right and the part that got me
was you can drive more yield and take
the same amount of risk right and then
you do have to deal with customers the
yield component that's because like
right now when people bid on compute
space yep on AWS right and when they're
doing that there's a limited amount of
margin you can capture and really
margin you can capture capture is a
function of demand right there's a sign
demand component people don't recognize
is mining is the same thing but in
addition to that supply and demand sort
of price point you also have this
inflationary reward in a lot of these
protocols right and so I think what
people aren't understanding is the
intractable relationship between
protocol design and physical compute
implementation and this is where I think
the idea of decentralization really
isn't truly possible until we find a way
to remove this compute infrastructure
constraint that's where I think like
really really new ideas around consensus
designs so Algar and gossip protocol
gossip passing protocol
she and space mesh so there's very
different implementations of proof in
space and time even I think some of what
file points thinking about is really
thinking about like how do you
disintermediate and decentralize the
compute there and to me that'll be the
narrative that dominates crypto from
like 20 20 20 25 I don't know wild ideas
super fun though I love is just such
these are such fun thorny problems and
sometimes thinking about them like makes
me dizzy but yeah that's really
interesting